in an election this unpredictable hard
information is at a premium
unfortunately there's a lot of it about
detailed constituency polls are being
carried out intelligence that in the
past was the preserve of party HQ and it
all comes from one man now I've always
been fascinated in what makes a voter
put the X where he or she does formerly
a Tory donor Lord Ashcroft is now
reaching into his deep pockets to fund
polling on a fairly epic scale I'm not
in the business of predicting I think my
mantra is that a poll is a snapshot not
a prediction no snapshot has been more
eagerly awaited than his first of
Scotland due to be published within days
the talk is that voters here are ready
to administer a massive rebuff to labour
are you in a position yet to say whether
or not you think this SNP surge is for
real yes I believe it is real so dozens
of labour seats to turn SNP at one would
expect to see a surge in the SNP whether
it's of the same magnitude as I've seen
a few of the pundits forecast is yet to
be seen but we'll have a much clearer
analysis and the way he talks you think
labour is being overrun in Glasgow for
example which has been a Labour
stronghold area have the greatest number
of people voting for independence at the
the Scottish election so you tend to
want to ask why wouldn't they vote for
the SNP in the general election
disaffection is driving voters into the
arms of others - is this Westminster
parties reaping what they sow
the Conservatives must take a large part
of the credit for the rise of you Kip in
the way that they have handled the the
rise of that party so I believe the UK
phenomena is both the arrogance of the
Conservatives and the complacency of
labour that has given them the position
that they have but this was something
that was waiting to happen
Lord Ashcroft declines to speculate as
to how long this man will run
fixture of our political life however it
could be argued where you keep our
concern that perhaps for their long-term
interests a Miliband government is the
best even though they would not get a
referal arguably wouldn't get a
referendum on Europe because that would
give you keep another five years in
which to build their party whilst they
still have Europe as the bogie his
polling tends to show labour ahead in
Tory battleground seats we visited in
recent weeks like Cardiff north or
Hendon but law - Croft believes voters
may demand more than just banging on
about the cost of living for 98 more
days so what is the policy behind the
cost of living crisis we've already seen
that the policy of the freezing of
energy prices has gone away and most
voters are able to see the fact that the
reduction in energy prices isn't
anything to do with labour let alone the
conservative coalition it's it's a world
phenomena so what does what is the
policies behind it and I think there's
something lacking there you can sense
his skepticism about the current
political crop I believe that many
politicians who seek the Democratic
mandate themselves do not know exactly
what moves the X from one box to the
other though they believe they do and I
found that very fascinating to listen to
politicians who believe that certain
policies or things that they do will
persuade the voters to come to them but
yet when you go to speak to those groups
of voters it isn't correct not so long
ago you'd need 40 odd percent of the
vote to govern here
more recently parties have won with
shares in the mid 30s but labour and the
Tories are both in the low 30s now and
falling it is possible for someone now
to have an overall majority with a
national vote share with the two in
front of it do you think the voters
would view that as acceptable as a
legitimate I think that would then be
pressure as to whether
first-past-the-post is the appropriate
system of government in the United
Kingdom
that again is another debate for another
time there could be a few of those big
questions hanging over in peace by the
time they return here in may Joey Jones
Sky News